hi i am da long
and i am party leader of bündnis 90
the greens why with the greens of all places
because I want
that also my children
and even the grandchildren
have another planet
on which they can live well
the green
were actually always against weapons
and war why do you demand weapons now
for the ukraine
because the ukraine has a right
to defend oneself
and when
this right should not remain pleasant
then it is called
that we support them in doing so
what do you do about it
that everything becomes more and more expensive
firstly,
we support people
from the rising prices
are particularly affected
so just people with little money
or refer to people for example hartz iv
and secondly we make sure
that humans become independent of fossils
than from gas coal
and oil and they are particularly expensive
that means that is also social
remains environmental protection because of the war
now actually on the track
all the way in we even get much much faster
because everyone now understands
that energy policy is security policy
that means now we can have a new track
finally to turbo insert
okay is the 1 5 degree target
still to be achieved at all
yes the ipc report has also shown this
we are far from it
but it is still possible
last in what way
plays your bisexual role
very little in your politics